leave it to the women of the view to
identify the worst part of balenciaga's
child porn referencing little kid
featuring
BDSM photo spread that the luxury
fashion house published last week
according to Alyssa Griffin who is
supposedly the Republican on that show
the worst part of the fashion Line's
depiction of a frowning little girl
holding a teddy bear in s m gear
featured along with a handbag ad
highlighting a major Supreme Court
decision on child pornography the worst
part of course
is that it gave those mean nasty
conservatives an opportunity to pounce
what's going on I filmed this ad
campaign particularly distasteful um in
this moment so there's this there's
growing anti-lgbtq sentiment right now
and it how it's Being Framed is as
portraying you know trans people as
groomers this is a term you'll hear on
the far right they're groomers this is
where you get the anti-drag queen stuff
that we're seeing so Balenciaga played
right into their hands by having kids in
a sexualized manner carrying something
that represents you know sex acts I
think it was a really bad misstep at a
moment where it's just kind of a
dangerous time to even give Credence to
those kind of insane takes yeah I mean
we can't even show the picture because
it's so distasteful
damn you Balenciaga your portrayal of
quote kids in a sexualized manner
carrying something that you know
represents sex acts her words not mine
is playing directly into the far right
hands what a misstep now we're going to
have to hear more of those insane
right-wing takes that just so happen to
accurately describe what powerful people
are doing before our very eyes that
reaction from The View
it tickled me so much
that the the problem with the Balenciaga
Kitty porn campaign is just how the
Republicans will react oh you gave those
Republicans an opportunity it reminded
me of this Norm McDonnell joke I
actually think that the view which is
perfect because because Norm had this
sort of long and troubled history with
the view with the show and they they
were enacting this Norm Macdonald joke
where Norm one time he was describing
the real problem if terrorists were able
to get a dirty bomb and kill millions of
people
I can't say my friend's name but he said
his biggest fear
is
that Isis or some terrorist group like
that would get a hold of a dirty bomb
and exploded over a major city within
the United States
and kill
tens of millions of people
because then
the blowback against
innocent Muslims would be absolutely
terrible
yeah that's that's right that's true
okay let's do some jokes
you just love Norm's guest there she
doesn't
quite seem to she's too crazy she goes
yes yeah no that would be yeah you know
like if these terrorists
killed tens of millions of people you
know
that the worst part would be the
blowback the islamophobia the worst part
of the child porn campaign from the
high-end luxury fashion house is of
course the blowback that we see from
those Republicans right no I think the I
think the worst part call me crazy I
think the worst part of the weird child
porn campaign from Balenciaga is the
weird child porn stuff
you know and I I don't think I'm even
using that word hyperbolically
it's the children are clothed at least
that's good but they're there frowning
holding the weird s m teddy bear and
then in the associated game it was a
separate ad campaign but it was still
being featured by Balenciaga at the same
time you see a a reference to a Supreme
Court case about child pornography the
odds of this happening coincidentally
are
zero or zero okay I think that's the
worst part I think the Republican
reaction pretty good actually I'm pretty
glad there's a republican reaction to
call attention to this sick sick stuff
you know it's not a nothing Burger the
libs are going to try to say oh no it's
nothing oh come on you conspiracy
theorists you're overreacting uh I don't
think so look at the reaction to the
reaction from Balenciaga
[Music]